[Music]
all right and we could begin this is the
viewers twice class and if you have a
game at home you can send it to info
English Chess Club dot org and I'll
prints it out and I'll ball I don't know
and then we might look at it so yeah I
would doubt it
okay now I had a lot of people submit
their games but I just ate so I can't
look at most of them because I don't
think I could hold the food down no no
you guys play great I'm just kidding so
we're going to look at two games today
one game was played today at the Chess
Club and the whole audience is made up
of those players because we get a lot of
people here at the Chess Club and this
is my first time doing this class
because this is the greatest class ever
and I looked at all the games that were
submitted and this is the one that I
like the most it was very little
suspicious but only a little okay and
this was submitted by Mike Shoei against
a last name of Russell I don't know the
first thing probably Jack no nothing
terrier okay so uh the first one was
white it says 1,300 and the person was
black it says 1,800 so the USDF reading
and the guy wrote a long you know intro
it says We the People in order to form a
more perfect union establish justice oh
I got something else okay so he wrote a
lot of stuff and then I have to delete
it okay so let's have a look at the game
the person who submitted the game was
white and he had a 500-point upset or so
he says okay he plays d4 now this move
is so bad I almost have stopped looking
good thing right now but I think I'll
give him a chance we'll look at it again
okay so g4 d6 now a lot of people
including some people unrelated to they
close their eyes when they play chess
and they make the first like seven eight
moves no matter what you play and a lot
of these people are people who play the
London system and people by the London
system with white they play d4 they
don't care what you play then they play
Knight f3 or Bishop f4 and again okay
what you play and they just like the
same few moves now white did
that except white played super
aggressively in the middle game this is
actually a good way to beat a high
related player even though his woes were
very suspicious
they were complicated and too
complicated for his opponent to the
point it went down in flames so he
played Bishop f4 which is not a move
that I would play when my opponent plays
d6 because my bishop on f4 is like sort
of hitting up on chain and I can't
really do anything great but some people
just let this same moves and they don't
really care what their opponent does
this is enough force okay it's not the
losing roof not yet okay
so then they played sort of Kings Indian
ish London style okay and these moves
are all reasonable now white tight tried
to transpose into one that I play with
white and sometimes in the King's Indian
when I play d4 and c4 and move my
Knights out sometimes I play Bishop f4
and e3 I don't do it all the time but I
do it sometimes here since blacks Bishop
is already on g7 and he has this nice
diagonal I definitely would play in
London style by playing c3 at some point
and trying to thwart the bishop but
white played c4 and that's okay but it
makes it hard for what you defend over
here because his bishop can't get back
there and most grandmasters and most
chess books recommend in these kinds of
positions with as a bishop on f4 if
you're considering playing e5 or c5 the
usual Kings Indian type of breaks they
recommend c5 because that way you can
try to take advantage of this diagonal
you can play Queen b6 and try to punish
him here and that puts a lot of pressure
on White's position because if white
plays d5 he could get in trouble in that
diagonal okay now black did something
else which I like he tried to get the
bishops and a lot of times in the London
white plays an early age three so he can
preserve his bishop might come were
approved about usually age six and so
black played Knight h5 which makes a lot
of sense trying to get the bishop and
normally black white is going to move
his bishop around a lot and make white
make black I should say weaken his pawn
structure so something like this would
be
some kind of normal idea I don't have to
play Bishop g3 here but let's play
anyway and now this position you could
see that probably black having his pawns
here instead of you know back home on h7
and g6 makes it easier for white to
attack on the Kings side so a lot of
times White's going to play Knight c3
Queen c2 and long castle and then try to
do some kind of attack and over here on
the Kings side why did do that but he
didn't make black move his King side
pawns forward and that's not four so
that's like a normal idea so instead he
played bishop g3 right away
normally when I'm white in these kinds
of positions I hope that my opponent
takes my bishop right away so we can
clarify the situation although here if
black doesn't take the bishop white
could probably play Bishop h4 at some
point and then I'm not sure why the
black knights on h5 the Knights on H
five to take the bishop lead to position
okay and black played nine c6 which I
probably wouldn't play but it's okay and
now white made a move I don't really
understand
I don't think white understood is either
so this was the first move of the game
that I think is pretty bad it's Queen c2
I mean Knight c3 as a standout move the
Queen on c2 can get harassed by Bishop
f5 or ninety for the Queen's on c2
basically so I can Castle queenside
which is what white did later but I
can't Castle queenside yet because my
Knights on v1 so I'm not sure my Queen
should go and in fact that Queen made a
lot of moves and extra moves that Queen
was moving so I would I would play
Knight c3 here for sure and then I don't
know I probably prefer black but okay I
would have white because that's the kind
of player I am okay so Queen c2 and now
I believe it these kinds of openings
black should try to play c5 when the b2
pawn is not defended by the bishop but
by clay 96 so now if you play see if I
that's even more cheating than I do so I
play d5 makes sense because white play
Queen c2
his deep on is really attacked now the
queen is not defending it and in fact I
like to take some openings and compare
them to other openings to confuse my
students even more and the more confused
they are the more money they give me
because they're like what are you
talking about
then then turn them upside down and
there's no money okay
and in the Queen c2 nimzo-indian which
if you've watched my youtube channel or
this YouTube channel or chess kid comm
or chess comm or you're following me
somehow and I don't even see you but
you're watching my videos I play a lot
of Queens you tuned in Zozo make a lot
of videos about it and my deep one is
not defended as much because I moved my
queen away from my deep line and this is
the same pawn structure we have a policy
for a pawn on d4 except here I'm not
sure why I play Queen c2 the Queen
students out you're defending your
knight you're defending you Foursquare
so now the e pawn is attacking the D
pawn that's just hanging so white has to
do something about that white play d5
that's probably what I would play it
right before attacking the Queen white
saw it attack in the night and now white
sort of messed up his pawn structure by
playing a three
because after Knight a six we're going
to play Knight c5 with tempo and then
we're going to play a four and that
means the Knights going to stay on c5
for a long time normally in a King's
Indian especially if we're castling
kingside
if black ever plays Knight d5 we want to
be able to kick them out with b4 well we
can't do that because white played a
three and blacks going to play a four
and block it up good thing for the on
passant rule okay because then we have a
Canadian here on pizza alright so why
play d4 which is I don't want to say
it's not it probably is the best among
whites losing a lot of Tempe wife's
playing Queen c2 White's playing Queen
b3 White's playing Queen c2 here wipe
like III wipe like efore white moves
Bishop to f4 and G 3 because wife's
moving the same pieces two or three
times you can see that half of his
pieces haven't moved yet even though one
move 14 they have been a lot of fun ones
okay conversely black has moved
everything that's important except his
bishop
he got his night to a good square he
Castle he has applauding the center he's
ready to play f5 he can move his bishop
if he wants to but he played the
positional move which is actually very
important for the audience he plays the
move a4 and that fixes the Queen side to
the young passant rule and this pawn
structure in a king's indian if you see
this that's good for black and normally
what white does if black ever gets in
night c5 and a5 is white plays b3 before
he plays a3 and the reason is if white
plays if black plays a4 white can play
d4 if the pawn can be three you can't
take it on passant but here's the pawns
I'm b2 so it could never move now I was
complaining but I probably shouldn't be
whites not gonna play b3 or be four
because White's gonna Castle queenside
and plays for checkmate down the h-file
very suspicious but it worked so that
very suspicious okay so I was
complaining earlier that white didn't
play Knight c3 and then he showed me he
played night BD 2 which actually makes
more sense because of this b3 whole so
now not only is he defending Z pawn but
he's defending b3 probably better than
Knight c3 so there you go in black light
f5 and White Castle queenside now when I
was playing this game over quickly
earlier I was like wow blacks playing
great black played 9 h5 and took the
bishop black played f5 black clay Knight
c5 black played a4 and white made a lot
of moves that I wouldn't have made white
played Queen c2 Queen b3 Queen c2
that's not very effective white clay III
than e4 and black has the two bishops
black has more space on both sides of
the board White has more space at the
center but the center is blocked so I
really like black here I was like boy
Black's doing great and then black got
destroyed got crushed and I was like is
it me okay because usually it isn't me
you can ask any my wife and I put this
on the engine and the engine said it
wasn't me it was the person playing
black here okay and here black started
to make mistakes and I tell all of my
students this and someday one will
listen you can play as many good
you want and your particle plays many
dead moves as they want and that will
happen and the computer will say you're
doing great then you make one bad move
and another bad move and you're losing
so you can't just stop playing well and
here black made his first mistake I have
a rule never trade you all know that and
here white doesn't really have any
active pieces and I can't really suggest
to move to activate them these are the
whites three minor pieces and if I was
to move one of them I don't have a lot
to suggest I mean they're sort of okay
where they are so if I'm black I'm going
to try to develop or increase my
advantage somehow either Bishop d7
developing my bishop or c6 attacking the
center or I could be creative and put my
work on the B file that's too creative
for me I could play Queen f6 just so I
have more attack on the F file and more
defensive my F pawn like Queens not at
home anymore I have a lot of moves that
are reasonable black took on e4 because
a lot of people feel compelled to keep
moving forward and getting stuff done
that gives away some of his advantage
because now the white knight on e4 is
very strong and the black light on c5
was immovable that was the greatest
night ever that nights that Knights
there forever and you can't attack it
and then blacks like RI you can tack it
back get rid of that good night so if we
trade nights then blacks beautiful night
on c5 is gone so black pins the night
and developed a piece make sense and
white played Bishop to d3 and now black
made another mistake I would take that
Bishop all day okay I would Adrian
Peterson that Bishop because then I have
the two bishops against two knights and
I dominate the white squares and black
made a decision that I don't like he
played Knight b3 check forcing King b1
how could you force your opponent to
play King b1 I always play King b1 and
then he played Knight d4 another
decision I don't like okay and now I'm
opposition's prob about equal
I mean blacks Knight has gone off of c5
White has a knight on e4 somehow it's
illegal but he still did it
and why can solve a sudden movies
kingside puns
okay the kingside plans are fluid and we
have the open h file still and I'm not
sure what black accomplished in the last
five moves basically how Twite and now
in the notes to the game white was very
proud of this move and said it was like
an evidence game but on the other side
of the board but this was looses a pawn
so don't do that
if you're taking notes don't do that
I'll let them take notes oh here's a
drink well water okay so white plated
move recommended by Matt Larsen g4 okay
and it sacrifices upon but I don't know
why so he lost upon hereupon doesn't
matter a lot because it was doubled but
he wanted to play f3 and g4 and he did
play f3 and g4 I'm not lying to you so
if I was white and I wanted to play f3
and g4 guess what I would do I would
play f3 and g4 okay and he did it were
lost to pawn so I would play up three
here than g4 alright so he played g4 I'm
taking the pawn is good okay now the
next one doesn't make a lot of sense
unless you follow it up with taking the
night so I don't I think the guy changed
his mind I think if he didn't change his
mind I'm baffled he played this ship f5
which is okay this should be sevens
banner but there's no fives okay an
exhibition about 5g for you you take the
knight on e4 and I guess I prefer black
because black supply op okay but he
played g4 then Bishop g7 so he let white
play g4 for free now could be he wanted
white to play g4 because he thought the
f1 was weaker so he was like egging
white on to play g4 maybe now I wouldn't
egg my opponents to play g4 because
there's no point on g2 actually because
of that there's a movement white plate
here which we see in the dragon Sicilian
sometimes and we also see in a line that
I play widen the Queens gambit declined
there's a line with white where I play
trade everything I move my Queen to d2
or c2 I Castle lon and I push all my
king side pawns and if you push all your
Kings side pawns and your Queens out of
the second-ranked and some Sicilian you
can usually play Queen age too
this actually happens in the dragon
because of the dragon blacks playing g6
Bishop g7 and in the Yugoslavia TAC
lights playing f3 and often whites
playing g4 h 4 if you pledge the dragon
Sicilian with Wyatt
well since white played g4 and f3 we
could play Queen h2 if my opponent could
play Queen h2 I would hope that they
didn't therefore in this position I
wouldn't play Bishop f5 because I'm
helping my opponent play g4 Queen h2 so
I don't think blacks are queen h2 I
think if I was black and I saw Queen Age
2 I would be upset about that I don't
want my opponent to do that okay so h6
is forced because you don't want to get
crushed down the h-file
and you don't want to play h6 because
you moved all the funds in front of your
King you would like them further back
and so now White's position is very
reasonable I don't know if White's
better or whites winning but White's
doing okay and over the last 10 moves
the positions really change white
basically couldn't do anything and I
don't like what black did and now
White's really attacking he continued
his attack with g5 and it doesn't matter
what your opponent's rating is that they
checkmate you you lose the truth hurts
okay and he wanted to keep the file
closed he played h5 which was correct
okay now white went all-in and instead
of black calling and having a good
position he folded okay and folding
wasn't the right option here Knight f6
check is all-in and after Bishop takes g
f6 he went all-in again with Bishop take
g6 so he didn't mind sacrificing a piece
because he wants to play Queen Age 5
very scary now as you all know and when
I say all of you I mean you and not you
at home there's a camp going on here
right now and it's the top juniors in
the country aged like 9 to 14 somewhere
in there and they're all between 2000
and 2400 for the most
there's 16 of them possibly 15 I think
one didn't show up anyway the camp is
the US chess school Camp saw Greg shot
easier he's the US chess school AVI
Friedman who runs the shine Friedman
foundation no some made-up name and I
think it's actually mark shine they
actually know who it is and Armenian
Barsoomian who's an I am from California
who's GM strength is and they're
coaching the camp here and today and or
yesterday the day's sort of run together
Armand was excited was today Armand was
one of the kids to raise their hands and
confess and he's like when you're being
attacked do you get scared even when the
attacks no good and one kids like yeah
was always attacking me oh my god and
their kids were like nom nom the
greatest okay and Armand said it's very
common when somebody's attacking you
whether it's good or not you're scared
because you get made it in one are made
it into or your kings in trouble and you
figure if you're better than your
opponent and in this case 500 points
higher rated you can beat somebody from
almost any position but now when they're
mating you if they make you then you
can't use your extra rating points to
trick them so here uh black made I think
it was the losing move yeah he made the
loosely move here and this is a very
difficult position the best move is very
hard to find
I wouldn't expect anybody here to find
it so let's ask the audience the
computer gives this a zero zero zero
saying this as a draw so who can find
the draw what's the best move for and by
the way you remember earlier in the game
when I was complaining about ninety
three check and then white played king
b1 and you guys were like then always
says play king b1 but why what's wrong
with him okay there's a lot of things
wrong with me but me and my king on b1
is safe and if it's not safe if I go to
a two if my king was on c1 where it
normally is when you Castle black would
have an extra tempo by checking that
he'd get his pieces back into the
defense the King on b1 he got nothing
so here black needs to gain a tempo and
he has to play a move which looks crazy
because it forces white to play an
attacking move but the attacking move
doesn't
work so blackened gone so how do we save
our bishop and gain a tempo anybody
giving you a hint this should be five is
the right move attacks the Queen right
so the obvious move is we take stage
five not again
this is what Armand was saying today in
the advance camp he was like with the
guys attacking you you're scared but you
can't be scared when you play chess you
have to analyze variations okay white
doesn't have 7,000 threats here White
has one threat once is one threat Queen
h7 checkmate so we play Queen seven and
that's right
I'm piece up and the computer says it's
a draw because white checks and black
moves out of check and white checks and
black goons on a check and okay draw
okay and you can see that it's hard for
white to put more pieces in the attack
unless he's playing bug house then you
can do it but for example if it was
blacks move here I guess I could play
Bishop f5 check and trade bishops and
then I don't know I'm a piece okay so
obviously for a human it's really hard
to play black here because you're really
scared okay what the computer says it's
a draw okay and when people are
attacking you it's easy to make a
mistake because you're too scared
so here black played King g7 which gives
the piece back and he was probably
thinking he'll play rook a Jade and
defend they make sense okay and then he
takes f6 check was played and taking
this looks exceedingly dangerous so he
played rook takes and this is funny
because normally lower rated players
don't like to give all their pieces away
on purpose they just do by accident but
here he was doing it on purpose because
he wanted to attack that King and he did
something more if you would be proud of
here okay because more if he was always
using all of his pieces to attack you
can see the one white piece which isn't
attacking at all and he played ready to
g1 now according to the engine White has
more than one good move here White's
basically sacrificed nothing and he has
a safe King and black dozen but he sat
to piece and he's like man I'm gonna go
get your king and yes sir Sarah Wan
would agree with blacks next mover
though he wouldn't have black here
somebody's mating you might as well be a
piece up rather than not be a piece up
might as well have the extra piece but
if they don't make sure you'll win if I
don't make sure when your honor but she
really your still not better so I dip
the piece but obviously any Grandmaster
looking at this has never been so scared
we have a look on a a doing nothing
white has this huge attack and black
spot material that's not good okay so he
took and white crashed through check
check and now he played a subtle move
usually lorida players just keep
checking and that might have worked but
he played rook g1 with the subtle threat
of rook g8 maids the truth hurts there's
not a lot of defenses to that not a lot
so I like the way that white was not
intent on just checking every move it
actually found a quiet move pretty good
for 1300 black played Bishop f5 check
when I first saw the game and I was
playing it over quickly I didn't
understand why rich g8 wasn't made and I
was like oh you're in check I could
safely play rook g8 though because then
if I take it back I can do something
else because I can't move my rook so my
illegal move would still win once was a
blitz game take my king okay so he took
and now it says King e7 the game ended
so I know flag play King e7 then
resigned I don't know maybe here white
has an infinite number of mates
I thought chess was finite until I saw
this position however there's only one
mate in one who can find it in this
brilliant class I'm teaching you said
yeah Nate yeah yeah right right there
yeah yeah it does the best yeah okay
so everything else is made to where g7
Queen e6 Queen h7 escalated maybe if I
don't see how Queen g5 leads to mate I
don't know how but rook e1 so after King
g7 the game ended so I don't know if
white mated him or blacks like man this
isn't good
and you'll notice the whole game I move
35y didn't move his rook and white got
action all of his pieces involved and
that's how you'd be the higher rated
player you attack them and if they make
any mistakes at all mate if you don't
attack them and they make a mistake you
might be a pawn up and they Beach anyway
so it's good if
techadon I make a mistake like all meat
good so basically black was playing
great until move 18 and then I don't I'm
sorry so move 16 I don't like fe 4 I
don't like Knight B 3 check
I don't like 94 I don't like this [ __ ]
about 5 I don't like this of g7 and King
g7 is the losing move he had to play
Bishop e5 and it was still would have
been a draw according to the engine so
after white sort of god I'll played that
game then he outplayed black by getting
this attack which probably shouldn't
have worked but that's why you submit
the game is because sometimes they work
okay now there was a game played today
downstairs between two of our finer
students in the room there of the three
people in the room they're two of the
finest okay the two out of three and
that ain't bad according to meatloaf now
we have a big board because you guys are
big boys okay this game was played
between Isaac and Sasha the Battle of
the five letter names people hold on
your birth certificate is hey Sasha yeah
and think so also he's not Isaac no no
he is not yes his name tag he's not sure
sometimes but name tag now Isaac
actually works here and his brother
works here
so I guess white one so we'll keep white
at the bottom okay now I'm just getting
black one now they don't know so yeah
alright so d4 d5 now Isaac being the I
mean Sasha being the greatest person who
ever lived which is saying a lot played
the chigorin Gray named after mr.
defense I mean the in depth richer Goren
okay and that's a very aggressive
opening and so why did meet it properly
so black got a good game sort of like in
the first game and then black folded I
fold okay from Canada what do you want
so she takes d5 might be the best move
but there's a lot of moves that are good
that's that's one of them okay queen's
eggs d5 i've had white and black in this
position but not at the same time um III
is the common move here and it got more
common after the famous game that's
funny because I don't know ain't now
okay Lou and if AG you at home don't
know either right nobody in the whole
knows nobody home nobody correct against
now that's Clause because you
just picks away plays mr. Gordon ever
again that was good ya know cuz Barbie
von Schuch yeah and Kasparov won in like
23 moves and truth hurts yeah and that
game when eat is 10-15 years ago it went
a 593 Bishop here here here here
and I remember Kasparov played f3 Bishop
d3 92 e4 avon truck resigned okay now
the reason that's the main line active
Bishop d2 takes you can also take with
the bishop I want to talk about this
because if what happened in your game
actually and after takes
there's only one move grandmasters play
here only one of our nine grandmasters
play a lot of those but grandmasters
play one you guys know what it is I can
you figure it out what about you at home
now anybody Knight f3 is close you have
the right idea but you put your down in
the wrong square yeah because after 9 f3
F by Bishop g4 so night at 92 right
that's a Bishop g4 this is actually a
known piece sacrifice that nobody good
plays what's really interesting I've
analyzed it for hours and I can't
remember anything I just remember that
it's really confusing I've played it in
blitz and I always win but in the slow
chess I don't have the guts to play it
and so what I normally do is not play
Bishop g4 and take and just white
slightly better because White has two
bishops now I have this position again
starts with an S Selden Trimble
wow I figured it out do you know what it
is he's been to the club for like seven
years we've been here for seven years he
lives maybe an hour two away lived in
Colombia maybe
and he's 1970 to 2010 for the last 30
years he's an older man probably in his
late 60s early 70s unclear he's watching
sorry if you're like 50 he's not 50 okay
anyway I played Selden in this position
I was black as I pledged sure Goren and
Sal didn't took this they don't do that
yeah well now black just has a big
advantage white has an isolated blonde
the bishops here boo okay but nobody I
told him after the game to ID to the
movies like what it is not opening so
okay now in your game something similar
happened where there could have been an
isolated blonde but it didn't happen so
that's what happened so you played
Knight f3 which I've also faced be five
which is correct
93 is correct this should be force
correct
now everybody plays Bishop DD to accept
Isaac getting his opponent out of theory
good job okay so the main line is Bishop
d2 Bishop c3 bishops e3 e4 now I face 95
probably more than 92 and then it goes
takes takes 97 and in my opinion black
is a tiny bit better and I've won every
game with black I've ever had here okay
but my opponents always look rated of
course and also a move is Knight to d2
and I faced this twice recently in the
last five years and I played the movie
three
now I'm thinking I'm thinking with the
night I'm like what are you talking
about it's not white - if you mean black
smooth yeah you can do that right then
Queen a4 check for sure King at night so
you have to play 96 and then I could
take the point on e4 or possibly play
rugby one or possibly win it rook yeah
yeah they don't we all win although only
taking on g7 one okay so that's why okay
so you cannot play e3 or you can play
III I played III in the pro chefs League
against Michael Brown and I was better
at some point then it was a dead draw
then we repeated and I didn't want to
draw us I lost yes okay I showed him I
showed me our team still won
I showed our team but I didn't know it
was the last game of the match - it
could have been the drawing one the
mansion losing didn't but I didn't care
whatever I'll lose okay
so that's the main main main main main
lines there should be two bishops III
okay
you played III right now all that stuff
that I was saying earlier well now
because White's move order is slightly
inaccurate you can give them an isolated
pawn so you can take on d4 and white has
an isolated pawn and then you play chess
it's not word is probably equal but okay
instead you play Bishop g4 so he played
Bishop e2 which i think is forced and
now um I guess you should either take or
play E for don't know what I would do i
boy take on d4 because I like isolated
pawns for my opponent but you castled
which I would play in blitz chess for
sure in castle and now this is funny
because I've taught this many times
often in the chigorin the bishop is
pinning the knight and the knights
attacking the Queen that's a common
chigorin theme and after white castles
which looks innocuous all of a sudden
your Queens
okay and here maybe unlike every other
triggering position in chess history
maybe you should move your clean using
the two Goren when you're Queens attack
you take the knight which you did but
maybe you shouldn't here because the
whole point of 96 Queen d5e five castles
is to pressure this and then once you
play Bishop c3 that's internet and you
open the B file to your king so maybe
this is the one exception to the always
take on c3 rule if you move your queen
somewhere okay so Bishop c3 be c3 now
this guy's solid even though black
attacked it with all his pieces that he
got to play BC three so he's okay
and now the D pawn is really okay
because you play d4 okay then that
doesn't look too terrible 92
I mean h5 s an interesting sacrifice but
since you're from Canada you would only
play a5 not h5 so probably taking is
right all right now in this position we
tap of opposite sides and we haven't
completed development yet and White's
going to play c4 normally in these
positions of the chigorin when our puns
on e4 we play like Queen g5 and try to
do something with our bishop but you're
Richards gone so I can't I can't play
Bishop age three unless I'm playing bud
house it's not a lot of bughouse in the
camps maybe I can't do that so it's
really hard to attack here for black
because black has no pieces to attack
with and moving all of your pawns
forward takes forever and white has the
open B file so life's sort of ready to
attack and white has all these moves
that game time so probably I would take
I would take white here okay so you
played f5 bar AC for Queen b6 and
according to your brother the wonder you
won there's one game in the history of
chess in this position the players were
a little suspicious
they weren't grandmasters they
they weren't masters and white played
rugby one which looks very reasonable
and the engine says your move is better
because you prepared this before hand
and you played it to be - yeah this
ship's better on v2 than c1 yeah okay
and now you know you got to watch out
over here that's a nice bishop
okay Knight f6 I agree with that you
guys were complaining about age three
with h3 the chest move it stops 94 no
they don't like we extreme eight yeah so
you're better than you thought you were
you with some crazy comment he's right
next to you oh you mean in chess
yeah he's y-yeah yeah yeah okay and the
guy next time you ever saw before he's
black yeah yeah that's the famous argent
yeah you know I'm talking about yeah
famous on my channel my youtube channel
they'll spell your name wrong so can you
guys go to my YouTube channel and tell
them the scholars name right it's AR j
un j en that's i have it a name you guys
are the worst
okay back to our regularly scheduled
program alright so you followed the
Feingold's rule although i don't know
about that here when my opponent plays
h3 and they castle then i'm mating them
i mate them
so the plum really doesn't want to be on
h3 although I do recommend not getting
mated with 94 okay so when they play h3
I'm gonna cheat I'll be like Isaac look
over there and he will and then I play
g4 yeah and Isaac's like wait what I
must understand yeah okay so I'm
definitely like pushing these bonds okay
and I don't care if I lose all my pawns
as long as I made them so King B it's a
little slow shouldn't lose the game but
it's you're wasting a tempo because your
King on c8 I don't see how that's worse
I don't it seems like if he meets you on
the B file you could play King g7 so
maybe your Kings even safer on ca okay
so King ba Rick SP when I didn't
understand what the computer said it was
fine I would play Rick a b-1 but okay
whatever um and again Rick HG it is too
slow you got to be fast so that you
don't have to prepare g5
I win that you can play g5 there's no so
hurricanes g8 getting off of this
diagonal too slow rawr a4 okay
reasonable 97 sort of passive Bishop III
I like good news
okay Queen d7 and now the computer
really likes to move that you did not
play you played c5 and then the crowd
was booing until my throat was sore but
instead of c5 you should play Knight c5
now again you should have told you could
have told him to look over there then
you could have played 95 then he
would've been like I didn't make it to
c5 where was it so what are you
suggesting young man yeah 93 and 95 is
hard to stop because once he holds your
arms down otherwise 95 is coming yeah
the computer also likes a 5 c c5 leg
gives the d5 square away and blocks your
bishop
okay luckily it lets your queen get in
so it's good for attacking right but if
you play 95 that's also a good for
attacking and okay the truth hurts
alright so nice seat 93 is so good the
computer gives quite insane evaluation
like +5 evil at equal material crazy
yeah okay so c5 it still prefers white
c6 is slow because White's not
threatening c6 you could take it with
right so again I would be playing g5 g 4
or g5 f4 or put a knight on d5 maybe I
would even play the shocking moved King
a8 because I'm not really worried about
my a7 pawn he can he can't legally get
to it so I would be playing well if I
was worried about getting mated I might
play King a trick ba then I would be
less worried yeah
now the problem with c6 is you can't go
back to c7 if you go back to c7 it
wouldn't be so bad
so c6 permanently gives up the d6 square
which somehow he went to something any
sense for him so you mean when if I play
nine to d6 that's annoying right Arjun
okay so yes
six gives away gives away the d6 square
so it's not permanently yeah so a five
that's not so bad again I would man I
would I would play King h8 here and then
if he didn't notice I'm okay if he's
like man good move okay that's I'm gonna
try something all right
so 9 c8 defence I'm trying to push
forward but the game's not there
rook to b3 slow and steady wins the race
now it says rook FA we'll never know
which one because later black played
work he is after helping yeah OK ROCK FA
wreck a b1 look up 794 threatening 95
and threatening I guess 95 also a6 is
really good and a6 is good after 94
because you defend b6 yeah so this is
just winning because White's attacking
and black didn't attack evenly counsel
opposite sides so once one side
attacking one side isn't then as yessir
server would say you guys love Sarah one
it's a three attest you guys love Sarah
one you don't know what final says like
Sarah once is this okay but you should
have said it's a free attack for white
because white can play a 5 to a 6 or
night on c4 to e5 as in the game Anatoly
Karpov vs. Garry Kasparov
ok but hopefully he edits that or
doesn't come all right so now black
should resign but I'm just kidding rook
e8 okay and that makes sure that all the
forks are available okay and there's
Star Wars fan so they use the forks Ben
are you gonna leave in my yes or Sarah
want imitation alright yeah I would edit
that out now you can leave it in all
right now the engine is very keen on a6
because chess computers like to
checkmate their opponent so they're like
all a6 that checkmates my opponent and
then man I don't know what I would do if
I was black again I would try King h8
but now cheating loses because he plays
eight takes b7 then you still resign
well rook takes b7 867 is better so now
when cheating loses you know you're not
doing well okay but you played a 5a
didn't play a six you tricked us
good job yeah the only point of 85 is a
2006 when you like and it was really
good Hey okay so you played instead of
95 for king a queen and rook which is
recommended by your brother okay you
were as bob seger would say working on
your Night Moves okay so you played nine
two DS and you played nine to d6 because
you didn't care about any of these
pieces just as night on c8 not sure why
not sure why you want to play what move
let's ask a random person Arjun is black
ever going to play b6 in his dreams
what b6 the worst have I've ever seen
ever
and I've seen everything man you you
have every piece on the board defending
b6 and it opens up his King so you
prevented a move he would not play right
so uh and also that helps them play b6
because your pawns on c5 anymore okay so
96 not the best move but you're so
winning it doesn't matter and because of
your brilliancy you had the pawn on d6
just like you liked it for later you
knew you knew was going to happen you
knew you knew after the game you know
okay so you traded on d6 and
unfortunately your position was too good
okay now you finally play Knight d5
after he gave you d5 a long time ago and
then Queen a6 putting a lot of pressure
I like the way you played a5 but not to
play a six that's tricky okay and now
the engine says that white is winning
but barely after Queen c8 although still
winning two in fact pretty winning like
+2 maybe okay but I can see not playing
Queen SIA that looks really passive it
lets the D pawn move I would be scared
of Bishop c5 really Skinner Bishop c5
but the reason the computer is not
scared of Bishop c5 I think I'm still
scared of it I'm talking about it
I think black plays something like b6
and your discovery on his queen which
you wouldn't see so you take his queen
next move he'd stare at the b6 pawn and
evening all my queen I'm still probably
waiting for white man I wish I was
kidding you know there's a lot of stuff
there there's a rook that can go here
there's a lot of yeah remember you stop
b6 okay and then if Queens are traded
white will probably win a pawn but
that's what we call a Pyrrhic victory
that's what our Jim was saying I
couldn't stop Arjun from saying Pyrrhic
victory and I'm like stop right Arjun
see ya
by the way I was kidding about a b6 but
I don't know if I'm kidding anymore
maybe I am kidding kidding is fun is it
I don't know they want to hang my queen
I'm still winning that's probably a good
position for Wyatt okay yeah don't know
I'm too old for this but I'm analyzing
this and I don't know I'm old me alone I
mean it looks good for Wyatt but if
that's good for white that's a bad sign
okay so instead black played some
another move king a8 okay and that would
normally be a good move because you're
getting out of the pin and you're
tacking is Queen and I think you should
have played it a long time ago that way
a6 and Queen a sticks aren't as strong I
need to play with BA okay and white play
the good move so I pretty sure he was
using a computer somewhere because I've
never never in all my years yeah okay
hit make that joke man I can't make any
joke I mean I'm thinking of a lot of
jokes I can't make any of them I'll just
say Donald's that we could totally do
okay so I just said his name I didn't
say any Java Corey
okay so rook takes d7x clamp threatening
is that too hard for the class very good
Queen a7 mate black stopped it and then
rugby seven threatening yeah so he
stopped it
and then Queen takes e7 and says that
cause Queen 66 okay
now White has two threats Queen takes EI
and a6 that's a threat okay and you
might as well say d7 might as well say
King h2 all right and material is about
equal whites a little bit ahead but
there's too much attack okay now is this
forced to mate the engine announces mate
for every legal move but for those of
you who don't know why you - no well I'm
not sure if you either what he remembers
because game was played like two hours
ago but what is the quickest way for
black to get mated which he found so
what is this large electing me what's
the worst move for black although it
ends the pain
what's that no no no no he got made it
into one
you're just what's that man he's trying
to remember the play king b8
right yeah King B it is correct okay
and now the funniest part of the game by
far is black-white play checkmate and
white play Queen takes rook and then
black said okay and white thought black
resigns because why did know he
checkmated him and on the score sheet it
says resigns then he crossed it out and
wrote mate see that's funny that's good
not actually he knew it was me he was
just kidding yeah I know you know yeah
but I like the way you made somebody you
think they resigned I said mate against
somebody once when I was about 1900 and
they made a move and I was like oh then
i mated him later I was really sure
about I was like all right I don't want
to say it twice and again they claim I
draw the third time so yeah I said mate
and the guy who just king somewhere I
was like oh yeah that's better than what
I was thinking this is a slow game so I
wasn't always a grand Minister I would
something yeah I was you know night like
you guys I was I was something I was
alright let's see we have time for seven
more games 7:30 well alright so that was
the game as people set in
a plate here I'll look at your games
next week that you sent in I didn't have
time obviously I'm not Eric Rosen over
here and so forth I think the problem
was the reason we went so long today was
I did a yes or Sarah one invitation for
10 seconds and that's what 20 minutes
all right so remember send your games to
info at st. Louis chess club org and do
not send them to GM fine go to gmail.com
go do that and well you could print a
donation to me that night but don't send
a game if it's like a donation and it
games just don't do it
poor horrible ok and so for the Chess
Club lose classic center of st. Louis
and for presidential this has been
Feingold signing off see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]